so who are you hi I'm Kyra I'm an artist
why are you here I'm here for the
amazing film courage Clinton entry and
which video inspired you it was video
that I hadn't first chosen because many
of the videos on some courage inspire me
I have a lot of favorite ones that this
one has found me and it was mr.
opportunities in love and what screen
writers should know by Pamela J Smith
and where did you watch the video I
watched it on YouTube I watched on
YouTube a lot as I'm working and film
courage is always like our mentor and
tutor for me personally how did you find
a video it found me as I said earlier
anyone is surfing I was surfing a
cyberspace and there it was how many
times did you watch a video 10 because I
had a similar encounter 27 years ago in
Hollywood West and it intrigued me so
tell me what happened
oh my encounter 27 years ago was on when
someone glides in my eyes and engaged my
eyes and time Stood Still it was like a
moment where that one person on earth
showed me forever it was very
interesting so when you watch panelists
video about missed opportunities what
key lessons did you take away from that
video but there is never missed
opportunities on there's moments where
for myself personally I thought with my
experience that were driven to pursue
the things that intrigue us and that I
didn't take it as a missed opportunity I
took it as an intrigue to use my art
work as a calling so that's how you
implemented that lesson into your life
yes I for 27 years I've just been
building and building on my arts and
this is why I've never given
and I'd wanted to give up so many times
and film parish's keeps encouraging me
not to so what happened as a result all
I figure today and what are their
impacts to the video hand money that
people experience situations that are
interesting where we share an energy
flow with each other and that's why I
see now that we never have a missed
opportunity so what is your dream and
where do you see it taking you my dream
is to wake up every single day healthy
and live life to the fullest and to be
kind to others and wouldn't want to deal
with your art I would love to go to New
York and Hollywood left again and I'd
love to show my work in the Chelsea
Agora
Art Gallery in New York that would be
something wonderful what kind of art
they do I do a lot i cinematography I do
performance art I also do script writing
photography right now in digital art and
editing is very high on my daily
activities and I'm trying to prepare for
an art show thank you for this interview
and thank you so much and hello
everybody thanks for watching